hello and welcome to the new world
review
i'm grand line waifu do you have a
little time to speak about our good show
hunter hunter
i can promise spoilers and deliberate
specific
non-mention of particular items and
clothing and
all with the guarantee that no one will
be under your bed
like what you hear thumbs up or down
depending on your preference
and perhaps subscribe by signing this
dotted lime that has nothing at all to
do with your soul
ready for those spoilers let's go
episode 38 and 39
such a brilliant thing to learn from his
father the first thing gone learns
in fact that hunters are selfish
creatures
it's really interesting that jing tells
him several times that he doesn't want
to meet his son
jing starts out telling gon he doesn't
want to meet him then gives him clues to
meet him he knows
that if gone became a hunter it was
likely to hunt his father
jing definitely wants to meet gone but
only if gone's good enough to meet his
standards and of course
gone fell right into that trap the crazy
look he gets in his eyes when there's a
challenge
there was phenomenal and gave us great
insight into his plans
gone gets that look often right before
he gets very hurt but even more
interestingly he's drawn that way when
he's afraid the example that stands out
most was his first run-in with hisoka
as gone spoke to korapika about the
situation he said as much to karapika
that there was something exhilarating
about the experience but that he was
most certainly afraid of hisoka in that
moment if it's a similar situation gone
is knowingly walking into danger and
that's exciting
speaking of walking into danger it's one
thing for his dad to be perched on top
of a mini beast near a volcano another
to be perched on top of a mini beast on
top of a dragon near a volcano
i kind of was disappointed at the lack
of the mini beast on top of a dragon on
top of a larger dragon or maybe
a mini beast on top of a dragon on top
of hisoka that would be hilarious
anyway jing and gone are very much cut
from the same cloth and that is
somewhat comforting the idea that it
seems as though his dad is playing a big
old game of hide and seek the way he and
mito did is
odd but not all that surprising given
how this show has gone so far
about gone's mother there's so much to
be said about the idea that he didn't
want to know
about his birth mother at all it was a
beautiful gesture
and a wonderful experience to see him
not question it at all
but then to lose the chance to learn
about her at all as an audience member i
both loved and
hated that i want to know more now about
god's mother than
anything else and yet i feel content not
knowing this is one of the first times
in the series that there is information
actively given taken away and seemingly
erased such that we can't
have it and i'm very here for that i
love secrets i love being reminded that
i know nothing at all about a character
i enjoy
not knowing things and i enjoy wanting
to know things it's been floated that
jing knows who and where his mother is
it means i'm ready to dive into a new
arc that has promise of what a future
arc could be
there was also a very beautiful note of
gone confirming resolutely that mito
is his mother being willing to stop
listening is one thing
reaffirming without what seems to be too
much concern that it's not the loss of
the information of his mother but the
forensic information they could have
learned about
is another what it does mean now from an
audience perspective is that any time we
come across a woman who could
theoretically look like gone i'm going
to wonder if she's his birth mother so
don't be too surprised if i'm just
repeatedly saying
is it her is it her what about her and
her and her what about her her
her as an interlude the idea of a
magical boombox is one of my favorites
so far and it raises the issue of
items being enchanted in this world it's
a new and interesting use of nen
and while we've had examples of it
before such as hisoka's use of his cards
and the promise string there's something
about the use of it as applied to
technology
and the connection of that nen to
someone who put it in place
10 years ago it suggests that 10 years
ago jing was a powerful men user where
will he be now
what are we going to see now how many
times will jing turn up and leave
jingon hello yes it's me toughnut dad
and what was the second tape for did
jing use the second tape full of men to
record his son's responses did he make a
mixtape
even i a 90's chick who used to make
mixtapes from the radio does not
understand why the second tape was there
if
not to record a response that jin could
hear simultaneously
or some other kind of magicky nen neness
speaking of magicky nen-ness since when
was kilwa
a digital forensic scientist i know he's
an assassin
and i get that assassins have to
research but he surprises me sometimes
with his quick thinking we know he's not
gone but sometimes i want to know
more about how intelligent he actually
is it's not too far
for him to know about the joy station
joy station and it's not too far for him
to know about games especially given
piggy's
existence piggy i thought his name was
milky
so he's not a cow anymore he's a pig are
we just gonna work our way through
farmyard animals
what exactly is horsey doing now beyond
spending his time with big
busted um friend dolls
in front of his thousands of computer
screens actually never mind
i don't want to know so greed island huh
we only need a couple hundred
billion currency to achieve this
and greed island it's such a perfect
game for a hunter to be playing
here are my magical predictions because
this is fun
for me we're bringing the team back
together or at least korapika gone and
kilwa we're going to try to get hold of
the game but we'll probably struggle
because of the nature of an auction
jing will make an appearance but gone
won't see him maybe he'll see his back
as he leaves yeah that's a pretty anime
style thing to do
farm boy will have some kind of role in
this i don't think we've seen the last
of him but i feel like despite the
brotherly manipulation he'll still
somehow come through in the end
or we'll get the really dark way and
keel was going to have to kill him and
pry the game from his cold
dead piggy fingers either way i think
this interlude of beauty with warm
soft colors and the sense of
homelessness and warmth and kindness was
needed
because from here i expect everything's
going to get dark and gritty
his final night at home was the last
hurrah
mito knows how gone feels about her
without asking so she knows that if he
can come home
he will i get the feeling she always had
faith in him but now she has faith in
him caring enough about her to come home
something jing didn't have or give her
lovey-dovey things aside
let's discuss episode 39. the beginning
of episode 39
was a revision session of everything
that happened to korapika from the last
time we saw him it was a nice reminder
but i felt we got a little bit too much
information that we already had
that said if we were watching when the
episode first aired maybe it would be
different because that would
have meant we hadn't seen anything of
corapica for maybe 10 weeks and that's
very different to the speed i'm watching
at despite it feeling like i'm taking
forever to get
through this series i know you i know
where you are i know
i don't know where you are i know who
you are you people that want me to watch
entire arts before reviewing no i'm
going one by one very specific i enjoyed
the revision of the nen aspect and i
really enjoyed seeing the silhouettes
i've i'm
sure i've seen all the people with those
skills and their silhouettes
but being able to pick up who was who
has given more than enough information
to work from when i see them use those
abilities
we know that gone is an enhancer and
we've seen him work using his ability we
haven't really seen kilwa transmute but
we have seen hisoka do it so we have the
connection there
krapika conjuring his chains we'll come
back to those chains in a little bit in
fact because it's wonderful i'm excited
to see how our healer lay audio goes
emitting good vibes or just
sonic booms of complaint who knows and
our manipulator illumi we have
definitely seen
i want to see more specialist powers
though we've definitely seen another
manipulator this episode that bodyguard
she was interesting essentially we've
got her
and i'm somewhat here for it though i'd
like to see more femme characters with
some offensive abilities
particularly in terms of men use rather
than care and seduction the two we've
seen so far
they're fairly obvious powers to give
femininity but there is always time and
i hope we get more of that
back to korapika there's a lot new about
him despite the amount of time we spent
recapping before we got to new
information the new information we got
about him was juicy
and the new rage filled heavy metal
cords we saw of him were amazing
this previously carefully thought out
almost
soft character is now possibly the most
hardcore character in the series
his chain looks so thin with the little
ball in the end that in the last moment
of the episode i thought more of a garat
thin enough to look harmless but sharp
enough to cause some serious damage
there was something very interesting
about his teacher's awareness that to
become a good conjurer he would need
focus
imagination and training two of those
kurapika has shown us already
he's very capable of focus one might
argue he's overly focused on his goals
and training is definitely not something
he's afraid of but imagination i'm
excited to see what becomes of that
because karapaka's great at coming up
with plans
but they seem at first glance to be very
practical
that practicality rather than
imagination could be his downfall either
way
he has a pretty new skirt for the new
arc and i can't wait to see him fight
as a sidebar i just want it known that
i'm aware that as an enhancer gone is
inherently more dangerous than the
others but i haven't decided how i feel
about that as yet if it ever came down
to a fight between gon and korapica we
could reasonably assume gone would win
but we would have assumed that anyway
it'll be interesting if or when it turns
out that jing was the one who killed the
kurta that's the kind of dark i would
expect from this series so who knows as
a side note the sideburns of one of the
interviewees look like the eyebrows of
the dude bra in one piece who looks like
the other dude bra without the eyebrows
liam knows who i'm talking about this
guy anyway the dude here looks very much
like he'll be
mincemeat i mean he's just i don't know
that he can protect himself he
definitely looked very afraid
i'm very excited about the idea that
each of these people had their own
musical introduction
who is our new empathetic rat-faced
friend with the flute intro
i don't know if i like him or not not
yet
anyway have i already said how much i
love the music of this episode
i loved the music of this episode
every one of our new characters had
their own introduction that took us into
new genres
we had rat face with a sharp flute we
had the intense 90s street fighter feel
with heavy rock influences
we had the flute that carried over to
the bodyguard babe her terrified
employer followed by
the sitcom sardonic style in which he he
seemed to get
in someone else's car and drive away and
we had kurapika and
all the discordant piano that sounds so
painfully good with the rage and
determination he's feeling korapika is
finally at the point where
he can narratively start to achieve his
goals and we know that he's going to
do morally questionable things to
achieve them the music tells us that
obviously morally questionable things
like killing and maiming sure but i mean
morally questionable such as
potentially doing to others what was
done to his people in order to reap
vengeance on them there was a moment at
the end of the episode where i wondered
whether the boss was going to suggest
that
everyone in the room already had what
they needed as soon as we saw those
kurta eyes i was like oh
and i uh i do know for sure that the
person who saw his eyes is going to be
judging how hard it is to attain those
eyes by how well kurapika fights
i'm excited to see what kurapika has
learned and to see how he goes fighting
without his wooden swords the way he has
to now
i'm so very excited in fact that i need
to stop talking about this episode so
that's all from me
if you enjoyed this episode check out
this one and this one
and check out the discord and maybe put
your finger on your chin and say
i don't guard ugly men but i'm a babe
it's surprisingly self-affirming liam
can vouch for it have a great day